well the national rifle association has
put out a statement responding to the
shooting in uvalde texas you may also
recall that the national rifle
association is having its annual
convention in texas starting tomorrow
friday donald trump is scheduled to
speak there republican texas governor
greg abbott is scheduled to speak there
ted cruz is scheduled to speak there so
the nra puts out this response and i
don't know whether to call it disgusting
i don't know whether to call it depraved
or dystopian but it's definitely really
bad take a look at this
the nra statement on the shooting is
quote our deepest sympathies are with
the families and victims involved in
this horrific and evil crime
on behalf of our members we salute the
courage of school officials first
responders and others who offered their
support and services
okay although there's increased
questions as to whether how and why the
police confronted the shooter outside
the school
and then the shooter went in and spent
40 to 60 minutes shooting up a classroom
until police ultimately went in and
stopped him kind of a weird thing the
nra continues to say although an
investigation is underway and facts are
still emerging we recognize this was the
act of a lone deranged criminal
a lone deranged criminal
with really easy access to guns
with no requirement for gun insurance
with no limitations on high capacity
firearms despite being only 18 years old
thanks to in part the lobbying actions
of the nra
uh and by the way the whole uh you know
as they say here a lone deranged
criminal gets to the mental illness
component
also in a country that says half of the
country says mental illness is the
problem but they won't fund mental
health treatment
uh as we gather in houston the statement
goes on to say
we will reflect on these events
pray for the victims
recognize our patriotic members
in the midst of this your members or the
patriots what and pledge to redouble our
commitment to making our schools secure
so on the prayer
i'm a little sick of the after the fact
prayer once people are dead
if the prayer worked why wouldn't it
prevent the shootings if you pray the
right way pray to prevent the shootings
and yet they keep happening and the most
insidious thing is we're going to
redouble our efforts to make schools
secure
the nra exists to sell guns
okay
when they say
redouble our efforts to make schools
secure
they're talking about arming teachers
and arming everyone to sell more guns
for their clients their clients are the
gun manufacturers at the end of the day
a disgusting statement from the nra
obviously the convention should be
cancelled but in fact donald trump is
doubling down on speaking there and
we'll get to that a little bit later
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping